[Music]
hello
so good to see all you actual humans
tonight's speaker is actually one of the
speakers that uh we've worked with in a
way more than any other he's worked with
us on on many interval talks and so it's
great to have him here on this stage and
and this was you know there's sometimes
there's those books that come out and
every single person you meet says you
have to read this book um it's so
relevant to what you do and and of
course ministry for the future was
exactly one of these kind of books and
so we knew that we had to have uh stand
back for this and
um it was in a conversation i was having
with raw meznam who's going to actually
be doing our
question and answer who's also a
previous speaker here
who wrote the nexus series and is now
doing investment in cleantech i realized
there could be no better perfect person
to do the q a afterwards so i'm so glad
that both of them were able to come and
i think that
one of the the really interesting things
that came out of ministry for the future
was i think how many other
organizations
have been asking stan to
kind of
work with them around this concept from
that book and one of them was the uk
delegation with the cop 26 summit and so
tonight he wrote a special talk really
out of you know what he's learned from
both of these experiences and where he
thinks things are going right now and
afterwards
mez and stan will have a conversation on
stage it's kim stanley robinson
[Applause]
well thanks very much for that kind
introduction and uh appreciate much
appreciated
it's good to be back and it is good to
unexpected joy to see people
gathering together like this again
all come back
sweet
[Applause]
um i i want to before i begin i want to
dedicate this talk to michael mcgilligan
many of you knew him better than i
did so
tonight
i'm going to talk about the ministry for
the future
and cup 26 and what i have
learned six since cup 26
is it's um
a fire hose of information as we all
know
and
now a lot of it's getting aimed my way
by a kind of a category error because i
am an english major and a science
fiction writer
and um
that's all i am so
if somebody is actually coming to me to
find
solutions for climate change then we're
in terrible trouble
um and it's worried me a lot
but i'm beginning to see
uh things that i can do even as the
cardboard cutout
for the minister for the future and um
that's been a bit of a comfort and i'll
tell you about that journey
uh for those of you who have read the
book it won't need explaining but i want
to for those of you who haven't it's um
the idea came from me
came to me when i was thinking um
about this new information
that at wet bulb 35 temperatures human
beings will die
of hyperthermia that we aren't evolved
for it and it will be fatal even if you
were naked in the shade with a fan on
you hyperthermia would still kill you
within hours we just aren't set for it
and there had been a
movement
eco-modernism or maybe just your
ordinary environmental humanities
departments or philosophy departments
just saying humans are so adaptable
we'll just adapt to whatever temperature
happens although of course we should try
to mitigate but since we not going to do
it we'll just be ever so adaptable and
this was of course ignoring all of our
cousin species we rely on but it was
also wrong in that
vast swathes of the earth's surface
including
one of the highest wet bulb temperatures
ever was outside of chicago
so vast parts of the earth's surface
could become uninhabitable and suddenly
the 1.5 c
limit on temperature rise that had been
advised and got taken up as one of the
achievements of the glasgow
cop26 was beginning to look like
a necessary hard limit that we need to
adhere to one of several planetary
boundaries that we are plunging towards
in a trajectory that seems to say we're
going to be going past them
into um
toward a hot house earth status which in
the paleological past would mean almost
no ice on the planet at all etc in which
case we'd be seriously underwater here
i needed to write that and that's why
the first scene of the novel is in india
in one of these heatwave events and as a
shocking experience i know it was hard
to write it's hard to read and then
after that
a best case scenario
with that kind of a situation that we're
in in the 2020s i wanted to portray
30 years
going in into
a utopian space with utopia defined as
this
we dodge the mass extinction event
because everything else is recoverable
so the bar is quite lowered compared to
the perfect society of old
but um it would be a mighty achievement
if we were to indeed to dodge a mass
extinction event in the 21st century
given where we are and where we're going
so
this was the goal in my novel
i wanted it to
look and feel messy so that when you
were reading it you could suspend your
disbelief in classic coleridge style
you could um
this the willing suspension of disbelief
is the the joy of every reader of novels
lives and i began as a reader before as
a writer that's for sure
you read it you believe it and then you
come out it afterwards and you evaluate
it so to believe a positive feature from
where we are now i had to include
a lot of the bad stuff too and i noticed
now looking back at it
a lot of things i didn't notice while i
was writing it which i have to say was
about
six to eight months in 2019 a much
darker time than now i have to add
because it wasn't clear that trump would
not win and also the pandemic hadn't
happened yet and so it looked like we
were gonna slouch mindlessly sleepwalk
off the cliff
and in many ways the pandemic was a slap
in the face that speeded everything up
for both
ill and for good and so the dark stuff
in ministry for the future is quite dark
indeed and i wouldn't want to have
anybody take this book to be an
instruction manual as to how to behave
given the various murders and shooting
planes out of the sky that occur in the
course of that particular history
looking at it later i saw that for every
time something positive happened there
would be a reversal there were three
kinds of death and there's murder
illness and accident
um some major characters there's
um a sense that um of uh
desperate chaos that nobody's in control
and everything in other words that is
inevitably going to be the case
in the 2020s i wanted to represent in
that way and yet still show
a sequence of events that would get us
to a point like 30 years out although
now i would say the timeline is
completely wrong
and that everything that i talked about
happening in 30 years
needs to happen and will happen in about
10 years which is a shocking
acceleration but i think it's true
so i had
[Applause]
you know a
novel about heat death he
heat wave deaths of millions of people
and then how to techno um
you know political economy finance it
really sounds quite awful i mean doesn't
it as a novel reader it's like castor
oil it's already i had a reputation for
being the castor oil of science fiction
literature you know it's good for you
but you you're gonna have to choke hold
your nose as you as you down this stuff
um
a novel needs to be fun and so like in
new york 2140 perhaps they're having a
little bit too much fun in a world with
sea level rise 50 feet higher that was a
different time and a different kind of a
novel a comedy of coping i quite love
that book it is more fun but ministry
for the future had to have its own fund
and that could be in the play of forms
so it hangs on a regular novel that's
maybe novella length and mary murphy and
frank may the two central characters and
then their shadow badim
these for a long novel
the ordinary characters in it are just
quite few
but on to that i also hung
everything wikipedia articles meeting
notes and i had dramatized enough
meetings that when i discovered you
could just include the notes this was a
marvelous discovery uh nobody had to go
through another meeting in a room
it felt right and and it's probably one
of the keys to the book along with
the carbon coin which i'll get to later
and the um the sense of chaos and
disorder that the all the forms together
do
there's one more thing that i did that i
didn't realize till afterwards i would
divide science fiction up temporally
there's um
far future science fiction which we
would call space opera people are
zipping around the galaxy star wars
chart star trek space opera people know
what it is but it's a form of fantasy as
i tried to show in my novel aurora but
it's a great story space there's no no
knock against space opera not when
ian banks and gene wolf have written
that
ken mcleod
there's great space opera it's not
normally what i do in fact i think i've
only tried it once or twice
but it's out there and a lot of people
when you say science fiction they're
thinking just that but there's also near
future science fiction and those of you
sometimes you'll see neil stephenson do
it william gibson day after tomorrow
it's very common in science fiction that
the present is is presented
as a few years
pushed down the line with some classic
sf extrapolation of trends to show what
seems interesting and now it's a form of
realism to write now and reads as such
it's better realism than literary
fiction is with without a doubt
and that's a
a big part of why science fiction has an
impact in the world
then there's the middle zone
relatively deep populate
what i call it future history a century
out two centuries out three centuries
out
if you think about it you're not going
to find too many science fiction
classics that fit that song but if you
think about my career the mars trilogy
new york 2140 that's the year
2312 that's the year
uh it goes on like that um that is a
zone i find of interest called future
history where you actually see not just
what will happen with the present pushed
but what kind of historical change is
possible from where we are right now
and can you articulate it on the page in
a way that the reader can say oh my gosh
in 2312 i could be living on the moons
of jupiter and um visiting earth it
would be a wreck
they'd be fighting sea level rise and
they never would have gotten out of
their their poor old poverty traps at
old earth i think i called it
and and this is 300 years out and you
can say well yeah i mean it could happen
no laws of physics are broken it's not
space opera there's a history that runs
back to now
super interesting thing
well in ministry for the future without
planning it what i think i did by
accident was to
take
future history where history really has
happened and i jammed it into the near
future science fiction moment so stuff
that i used to write about happening 200
years from now i said look it's
happening in the year 2035 are starting
right now and will immediately
and this i think was like putting
together you know like let's see what
happens when we put together some
uranium with a little explosive force
and
it blew up in my face and and i've been
blown up ever since it got me it got me
invited to cop26 one of many rather
astonishing invitations over the last
year and a half
i was
feeling
surprised and then more surprised and
then after a while i thought
either i'm not surprised anymore or else
i'm permanently surprised which is a
great state of consciousness to be in
and we all should be wandering around
going i just can't believe it this is a
this is amazing because it is
i was at um
glasgow inside the blue zone my hangout
was the un futures lab when they were my
home base my my buddies they took care
of me and they gave me a closet to sleep
in if i had to take a nap and they
taught me things
and then and and i was really quite
comfortable there and it was a
tremendous education and at one point my
my main host a woman named coco warner
has worked at every one of the cops for
the un she said stan
who invited you here
and i thought it was her and i was
looking at her going oh my god i don't
know anything i don't even know why i'm
here
uh and i had to investigate i had to
pretend i looked there and i said
um well the invocation came from nigel
topping whose official title was the
high champion for crop 26 because the
british government likes their titles a
lot
the high champion was his official title
good guy and he was the one who invited
me and he gave me a red pass which meant
that in the blue zone i could go
anywhere i wanted
and this wasn't true for most people who
are observers you would get a yellow
badge and you wouldn't go into the
negotiating sessions that was for people
with red or blue and blue is this the
u.n itself
so there i was with this red badge which
nigel topping had given me
and i decided that the rest of the thing
being um kind of a trade show for each
nation would buy a pavilion in a giant
convention center and i i don't know if
you all have seen pictures of the blue
zone in a cop but it's somewhat like a
trade show or a circus or a
um
it's or a science fiction convention and
anybody who knows science fiction
conventions uh one of those for two days
is not bad for two weeks you have got to
be kidding me
um and yet
so i began to go to negotiating sessions
any kind of negotiating session and this
is very interesting
they were more than 50 women in their
30s and 40s lawyers diplomats scientists
they were working a document they were
editing together they were revising
editing
proposing
in
this is one kind of session anyway
document editing um by a ferociously
concentrated cheerful but meticulous
um
for my point of view young women and
with some elderly brit diplomats who
were staggering around with a limp and a
breeze case from bretton woods and it
was it was very cute how calm they were
compared to
everybody else there
and i was impressed by that and
then in other negotiating sessions in in
very polite tones of voice people were
arguing over money
and the developed world was holding back
their bags of money and the developing
world was saying you promised it and we
need it and in polite voices you were
seeing the incredible tight-fistedness
the self-destructive tight-fistedness
of all of the developed countries who
had promised money in the paris
agreement and aren't coughing it up
one of the developing nations diplomats
said to me that
the sewage budget for new york city is
35 billion dollars a year and the
developed world has just given us 20
billion when they promised 100 billion
and even 100 billion is
not enough but 20 billion is ridiculous
and that's where they were at
so this was a depressing part of glasgow
for sure but to see it all happen real
time
i began to understand
cop is just a place
to come and look at each other on an
annual basis to see what we're doing
in the rest of the world the rest of the
year
it is not the place of solving problems
it's there's no legally binding treaties
there and there's no sheriff nor a jail
if you were to break the promises or
even to leave the agreement outright
it has some beautiful mechanisms in it
it has an injunction to permanently
improve each time they meet everybody's
supposed to up their promises and make
things better and so it's like a ratchet
or a come-along
each year you ratchet up the um
intensity of the promises but their
promises only and i began to think
it's like a marriage
this is what you got to think of it as
you promised to spend your whole life
together and to do productive things
together
five years later you break up nobody
throws you in jail um hopefully and and
so what you've got at this point is a
world in which all the nation states
have in effect joined into a
a group marriage or something like a
marriage a set of promises to behave in
certain ways together and there's no
place to move if you get a divorce it's
like one of those
stories from my my my soviet agent
during the ussr days he and his wife had
divorced 10 years before but they were
still in the same apartment well the
world's going to be like that we can't
get away from each other and there's we
got i'm going to come back to talking
about the nation-state system
so
i'm
everybody i guess the last things i
would say about cop well there's a few
observations
it was a militarized site so the uk
government was really worried because of
world leaders coming or because of
seattle 1999
it was behind barbed wire and tank
stoppers the it was on the river clyde
so that there were zodiacs out on the
river with
military people and machine guns there
were helicopters just hovering
oftentimes especially during the marches
and the scottish people were loving
their marches
um i stood next to bill mckibben as the
start of one march we were like at the
parade marshals you know off you go off
you go and they were seeing mckibben
who's very recognizable going oh my god
you know it's saint bill is blessing
this march and they had taken their kids
out of school out of preschool it was a
family affair everybody had made banners
and posters
it's quite beautiful um
ten thousand people on friday a hundred
thousand people on saturday and about a
hundred people in us in a non-sanctioned
march where there were many more police
than there were marchers and i joined
all three of them
um but i have to admit that the big one
on saturday i only enjoined him because
i needed to cross the street and there
was no other way and so i went out there
and i joined a group of nurses and we
chatted for a while and i flowed
downstream for about 100 yards or so and
then got off on the other side and went
my way
um but it was quite beautiful to see the
civic engagement of the scottish people
with being the host of cop
and then
the results from it
were good as far as they go
but every diplomat and scientists there
the more they knew about the cop system
in the world the more scared they were
because although it is an admirable
system and way better than nothing at
all
it's too slow because it's built on a
consensus model every nation there has
to agree to every sentence
you saw an example of this in the last
hours where they were going to phase out
coal and at the last moment in china and
india and several other nations said
um oh gosh we can't do that um
we refuse and they went into a huddle an
overtime a couple hours of intense
lobbying and they came out well we'll
face down call and then everybody signed
off on it well this kind of consensus
model although admirable it's like the
general assembly without the security
council so it's a true
uh international body of nations you've
got all the people there but since they
have to all agree to every statement
as admirable as it is it's too slow
compared to the crisis i reckoned on the
train ride down to london that if we had
this is such a guess but it's a science
fiction exercise if we had 40 years
the cop procedures might work but we
only have 10.
so they're not enough and we're and and
we and i left cop thinking
we are in terrible trouble and nothing
in the four months since then has made
me change my mind on that we are in
terrible trouble but that doesn't mean
what that means also needs to be
unpacked
so um
in the months since then i thought it
would slack off it didn't slack off
and i began to
get quite nervous about being helpless
to suggest or say anything but what i
began to realize is i could take
somebody
who
was interested in talking to me about
topic x
and i could connect them up with
somebody else who was an expert on topic
x
and they didn't know about each other
because the world is too big and that's
interesting in and of itself that
although there's lots of good work being
done
not only is there no coordinating force
that's making priorities and linking
things up together and all that but
that's almost impossible in the in the
world that we're in who would do that
i'm involved with the un's 50-year
forecasting group and the un is doing
their damnedest to maybe rate and
prioritize
they're overwhelmed they can't do it you
would have to
postulate a a ministry for the future
that was a really good budget
and a huge team of people trying to sort
and connect and that doesn't really
exist but as my cardboard cutout
imitation of a minister i can now begin
to connect people who should know about
each other just recently
i met the woman who runs california's 30
by 30 program 30 percent of california
protected land for wild creatures by the
year 2030 amazing idea and i thought it
would never happen in my lifetime and
already they're shooting for 20 30 and
and they say well after we hit 30 by 30
we're going to shoot for 50 by 50 and
then we'll have a healthy biosphere
and california is an exemplary space as
you know and teaches the rest of the
world how to do these things and the
rest of the world teaches california
it's a super promising thing but she had
never met the head of the pacific
conservation league
which without this 30 by 30 framework
had nevertheless been working on similar
causes for the last
25 years
and i was able to say oh gosh you need
you know you're both in the sacramento
area need to meet they've since met it's
a productive meeting things will go on
uh it's been a pleasure for me
and when i was talking with this
jennifer norris head of 30 by 30 what we
began to discover together
is you need
the framework tail the frame tail
because everybody's individual efforts
are going to be too small to matter or
to change the world and you do what you
can and you're thinking well i'm i'm
swimming again i'm crossing the
pacific by swimming i'm in terrible
trouble here
because it's such a small drop in the
bucket or drop in the ocean but if you
see that
you're part of a larger story where
everybody else is also putting say
another analogy a brick in the wall you
work on your brick you know there's a
wall you'll stick your brick into it
this is a crucial realization for
keeping spirits up solidarity mutual aid
and it's funny when you think about this
wall analogy for one thing i build my
walls in maine out of glacial cobble
it's the worst possible rock to make
walls out of hilariously bad and every
every spring i go out there with my wife
and find my last year's wall has falled
down just from the freezing thaw cycle
and gravity
and that's the kind of material we have
right and also there's no architect and
there's no stone mason but nevertheless
this is how
group
projects work
everybody knows what needs to be built
and so you just put your brick in the
wall and you feel
that the concept of the wall is helping
so i think that that's another reason
why ministry for the future has had
people had a hunger for that story that
if everything that is possibly be done
gets done then even the bad stuff won't
be able to stop us from getting to a
good place now this is a
proposition not us obviously it's a it's
a science fiction story a utopian one
when i say that
uh i don't know if it's true and nobody
else knows either
the accelerated timeline everything's
going faster partly because of the
pandemic partly because no one person
can do the research to figure out where
the cutting edge is on all these things
so i was talking about a carbon coin and
i thought this was the idea of one guy
adult and chen in fact the network for
greening the financial system is an
organization of 89 central banks exactly
the people you want working on it and
they are working on it
the glacier geoengineering which i
thought had been an idea slipped to me
by a single glaciologist it's got really
good
papers on it in science and now in
science direct in nature in science
direct
there are new geoengineering methods
that are less intrusive and more active
than more
effective than solar radiation
management that are being talked about
all the time and 30 by 30 as i mentioned
when i read the eo wilson book half
earth i thought well this is utopian
science fiction indeed this will never
happen and now we're already on the way
to it and that was only 15 years ago so
in this excel we're in a moment of
accelerated danger and there's also an
accelerated response
so you can't
freak out
i say this to myself
um
one time i want to tell you about
freakouts
i was in the swiss alps
i had crossed a pass i sat down on a
point looking down at a
at a reservoir down below me and i saw a
helicopter coming up there was a little
hud underneath me it was closed it was
locked it had no signs on it
and um uh it was irrelevant and i
thought that this helicopter rising up
through the air was going to land at a
swiss alpine hut i could see in the
distance and resupply it which i'd seen
before
and it came up and it was facing me
and i was looking at the operator and
thinking why why is he here it was
really loud and i was looking right
through the bubble at the pilot and he
tilted in towards me and i be i got up i
turned around i went on to the flat
behind where i had been sitting
and he was i he was coming at me he was
coming at me
he was going to kill me i was in a
horror movie
i freaked out i turned around and i ran
up the hill like a bunny like you see
bunnies run when they know that they're
doomed i just turned and i ran and i
turned around again thinking oh god this
is so bad
and he was he needed to land on that
spot where i was sitting and he had no
way to tell me that i said ah yes i i'm
not in a horror movie after all you know
and i walked down the hillside to talk
to him about it
and i said geez i'm sorry about you know
sitting on your landing spot i just
didn't know and he looked at me he goes
really loud
and i realized that
helicopter blades as they're slowing
down
they become visible from the inside out
and what i thought was the end of the
helicopter blade was about halfway out
and there was a blur that i hadn't quite
noticed and i and and i was coming
downhill and the
rotors were
were drooping as they slowed down
i was literally 15 feet away from having
decapitated myself
so i i just gave up on talking to the
guy i took i went for the
the the swiss alpine huts have a thing
called cafe fertig coffee finished which
is coffee filled with brandy and i was
going to go get a cafe fair tag and
finish myself up and i had a the
sandwich that i'd been eating when this
whole adventure started was just
squished in my hand
there's a rib of dough rib dough i was
eating this dough thinking dang how
could have i explained to lisa that i
had died in a helicopter
accident by walking into the blades
but i bring up this story because we are
going to be having freakouts like that
what you know russia suddenly invades
the ukraine and it's a disaster
especially for the ukrainians and for
the rest of the world you get this ipcc
report the one that really
is the most frightening yet as they all
are it's news it should be the top news
in everybody's feed every day for the
next forever and it's buried by a war
and we don't know what's going to happen
next and these kind of freak outs are
going to keep happening as we go on and
even the war is a
as a result of a country that is a petro
state all the petro states are in
terrible trouble because they
get 60 to 80 of their national income
from selling fossil fuels which
supposedly is a stranded asset and
should go away since they signed the
paris agreement and you don't want to
cook the planet
well they're on the horns of a dilemma
with no
way out they're looking down the barrel
of a gun
save your country from complete
bankruptcy and social collapse become a
failed state or else keep burning in and
torch down the world and we're all in
the same boat
some petro states are going to choose
one and some of the other but we need
people who are right now talking about
exit ramps for putin
we need exit ramps for the petro states
because it's about a third of the
world's population that lives in petrol
states and they have no way to not be
bankrupt so the carbon coin is a great
idea you draw down a ton of co2
and you get paid a carbon coin and it's
worth more in fiat currency this is not
a cryptocurrency it's a fiat currency
backed by the central banks
and um
you get paid more you make more by
drawing down carbon than it costs you to
do that operation and you get paid for
doing the right thing rather than the
wrong thing carbon coin is i think the
central banks are already uh discussing
it it's a it could happen it's carbon
quantitative easing it's sometimes
called a real obvious idea but
compensating the petrol states and
here's where i'm going to end we're
going to have to do it or else we have a
failed states all over the world and the
world
falls into disorder and they go ahead
and drag their heels and burn their
fossil fuels in a desperate attempt to
stay solvent financially this has to be
addressed where are our economists where
are our
political economists in this world we
need that worked out i would say this
the payments you got to go to the petrol
states and say look we'll pay you to
keep it in the ground
the payments have to be amortized so
we'll you'll get payments over the next
century just like as if you were selling
the oil or coal or natural gas it will
be discounted wall street puts it this
way you got to take a haircut
you won't get the full value but you'll
get enough that you'll take the deal you
get a discounted and the discount rate
would be real interesting why should it
maybe be a bathtub curve you get a lot
of payments then you don't then you get
more later as a reward i mean here's
where the economists and people who like
to do gamification of human
motivation
need to get into that game and work the
discount rates
and then it has to be entailed the money
can't be given to kleptocrats on
autocrats and just banked away somewhere
else it needs to be spent on
decarbonization and that is an
imposition on national sovereignty so
there'll be squawks on all sides for
this deal the petro states will say look
we are a nation state we have
sovereignty if you're going to give us
money great but we get to do with what
we want because you you don't get to
impose on us
at that point
the people offering to give the money
you're going to have to say no that
isn't how this one works
and there you go from the nation state
to the member state and member states
have a different
relationship to sovereignty legally and
emotionally than than nation states used
to so the west failing system has to
shift
and maybe finance can drive it
into member states and all the european
nations are now member states of the
european union all the nations on earth
are members of the paris agreement so in
effect we are already supposedly member
states but of course the big bad boys on
the planet the the giant powers like the
united states and china
and now russia they don't want to think
of themselves as member states that are
beholden to anybody else sovereignty
still rules but the petro states might
be desperate enough to decide we are now
going to sign the fossil fuel
non-proliferation treaty or there's
going to be a mechanism that's part of
cop part of the paris agreement
where the the compensatory mechanisms
for
judging how much fossil fuel they have
and how much they get paid get worked
out in a big international agreement and
what i saw at cop26 it shows me that
will be enormously difficult but it's
better than crashing human civilization
so
um
that maybe that's a good ending point
better than crashing civilization we pay
off the petrol states we compensate them
we try to keep the whole thing going
in a collaborative manner we become
member states of a larger unity and and
we scrape through without the mass
extinction event hopefully yeah all in
there
i better
[Applause]
stan that was just fantastic
and always always a pleasure to see you
and to get the chance to chat with you
um
stan i just want to say before we start
i mean you you talk about yourself as oh
i'm in i'm an english major i write
science fiction and so on but i think
what you really are initially a
fantastic writer is you're a philosopher
like in your sci-fi you are
philosophizing about the future and how
we how we build that future in a way
that uh sci-fi that is
smaller in scope doesn't really do so
well i appreciate what you are
suggesting by that but i want to
i'm a science fiction patriot
i want to say that this is simply what
science fiction should always be doing
so that's the way i would put it is this
is what science fiction can do
relating to that one of the things that
i think is most interesting about you as
a science fiction author and also as a
climate activist is you see a lot of
a lot of climate activism that is very
sort of naturalist and as opposed to a
more
aggressive and ambitious interventions
and in in your books in in
ministry for the future but also in in
the mars series in the previous uh
science in the capital series in 2012
you are very willing to go to
a real focus on solutions that are epic
in scale that are massive human
endeavors where does that come from for
you it comes from stuart
no
we are a technological species we were
technological before we were human we
co-evolved with tools fire
stones etc so um
maybe this is also part of being a
science fiction writer i believe in
technology
but also justice is a technology
language is a technology it's a big word
it's what we do and now we're in a
desperate straits so i've been thinking
all hands on deck
really we ought to keep nuclear plants
going as a bridge technology to cleaner
cleaner maybe we might have to do some
modifications that people call
geoengineering we need to talk about
that a little more because there's so
many variants going on
but uh
and i'm you know me i mean many of you
do uh old hippie leftist
an american green
an eco-marxist american leftist although
marxist is really the wrong word and
eco leftist
the wobblies over
parties
you know my angle and from that angle i
say
tech
anything whatever works except for
fascism which wouldn't work anyway but
um but all of the things that we might
try we have to try see what works and
and
dodge the mass extinction event and then
solve the outstanding problems
fantastic well said
um
stan on the topic of technology that
works and geoengineering a couple
different people in the audience sarah
schubert
and paul baumgardt hi paul
have asked about what are these
geoengineering technologies you see as
effective but maybe less intrusive than
solar radiation management okay well
thanks i'm and i only know this
because of the last couple of months
running into sir david king um
the brit who was environmental minister
to blair and brown
sir dave is working on this at cambridge
university and i'm hearing things i've
never heard before
you remember iron filings dropped in the
ocean to create algal blooms that die
and sink to the bottom and the oceans
are already so sick everybody thinks of
that idea with a shudder of horror and
sir dave said yeah of course it
shouldn't be iron filings it should be
whale poop
i'm thinking what he asked well there's
only one percent of the whales that
there used to be they eat low they poop
high this is sir dave in a british
accent saying this exact stuff to me
it's a bio pump it helps everything you
have more fish you have healthier oceans
it it it begins to even
reduce the acidity it's like the perfect
solution we're going to send ships all
around the oceans
and we're going to have an artificially
mixed like giant oil tankers full of
artificially mixed whale poop jump drop
it overboard in a way that a whale pod
would and it'll even bring whales back
and then they can do it themselves well
i'd never heard of that before i'm
thinking
well what's the harm in it like what
will it hurt
um another one they said and this one
maybe is more well-known the arctic ice
is melting the sea ice the less and less
were terrible trouble up there in the
arctic worse than anywhere else
a lot of boats and he said automatic
boats like this new mayflower but i
think they could be crude why not be fun
shooting a very fine spray of salt water
so that there are salt crystals in it
just above the cloud layer and it
whitens and thickens the clouds and you
have a better situation in the arctic
and it's not particularly
like solar radiation management's global
monstrous thing and then the thing
that's in my book the pulling the ice
out from under the big glaciers in
antarctica to slow them down
that could be done oil industry navies
of the world
my next column in bloomberg green will
be precisely about this plan
and you think well that's so crazy no
one will ever do it but people do like
sea level they like the beaches they
like their coastal towns
and the fact that we could maybe we have
10 to 20 years to to stop the the
irrevocable
massive rise of sea level such that we
would be
um
really and truly this room would be
under water all right up to the ceiling
in certain scenarios pretty damn fast
so that these kind of these are the
things these are the kind of and there
are more of them of course you know on
the flip side i did hear that you could
buy
land at nevada prices it'll one day be
beach front value
yeah but it would be such crappy beaches
compared to our beloved sand beaches
this is why in new york 2140 and i think
in
aurora
people are dredging old beach sand out
of the shallows and reestablishing
beaches on higher sea level because i
want my beaches
kevin kelly asks are there other
discoveries or inventions outside of
sort of the geo engineering space that
you think are underrated or
underappreciated today
well i
i'm behind the curve on this
um i i stagger around i i would say
nature briefing science news
society for environmental journalists
and the american geophysical unions
magazine eos
these four things can
keep you scientifically literate
at a pace you can actually sustain
just recently i read about these deep
water pumps you just pump cold water
from it works best in the tropics if
there's a 20 degree centigrade
differential between the water deep down
and the water on the surface you can get
about a two or three percent
um efficiency rating of electricity out
of the hot cold water running a turbine
they warned us that if once you build 15
000 of these plants you might actually
change the temperature of the ocean in
ways that made it work less well
thinking okay we'll build 14 000
whatever
i thought that was rather exciting
because these island nations that are
already sinking they have to ship in
diesel at enormous expense and if they
had even one of these plants on their
island that island would be have enough
kilowattage to
supply all their needs and it's pretty
clean
they actually and you have little
lobster
industries
at the top of these cold pumps because
it's cold water in the tropics so
they're growing lobsters i mean it's
very funny there is a comic
level to it and i believe stewart has
always been very attuned to this there's
a comic aspect to our adjustment to the
world technologically and even though
we're under ferocious pressure
and it all could go crash and boom
um
it still has a somewhat to me it's it's
like well maybe it's like laurel and
hardy or one of these horrible keystone
cops things i mean it's funny to see
people in desperate danger
sometimes it is
um
but you talk a lot about economics in
the book like a lot of the book is
really not just carbon coin but other
things yeah one of the things you talk
about and a listener called uh paul has
asked a question later this is the
discount rate and how that changes our
calculus of investing to to save the
future and i didn't hear you talk about
it in the talk do you want to riff on
that sure i'll try to be brief
particularly since we're hitting the the
borders of my comprehension but um and a
lot of you will know more than i do the
discount rate when you're making an
economic calculation about how much you
should spend in the present to benefit
the future if you if they have the same
since the future goes out forever if
their
needs are equal to ours
then our we should be spending
everything for the people of the future
and not for ourselves so a discount rate
is introduced and william nordhaus won a
pseudo nobel prize for saying the
discount rate could be four percent well
this is just a robbery of the
generations of the future it's way too
high and there are some people arguing
it should be flat
some very good economists some argue it
should maybe be curvaceous and start
flat and then discount so you don't get
infinities in your calculations other
people argue the opposite you could have
a high discount rate and as you run into
the future in your calculations you go
to zero
well this is beyond me but it certainly
should be a big topic of conversation
because the future gets ponzi schemed
when the discount rate is too high and
who would who would make a decision on
that or how would that get determined or
how that would affect this country okay
but well this is a modeling exercise
economist so neoliberal economists would
say
let the market do it and um we'll just
let the group mind and the algorithms
the the ais
all this fear of super ai i mean kevin
is very reassuring about this in ways
that are important to me but if you give
over the ai over to ai to algorithms
your financial calculations in modeling
you can indeed just dial it yourself and
begin to tell
business leaders and government leaders
the discount rate needs to be
um
zero and then shading up to
two uh when you get to people that are
200 years out in order to make your
calculations work see what that does
they should be played with like a dial
effectively it's a it's an ethical dial
it's a moral dial how much do you value
the lives to come after us and
to be able to put a number on that is of
course the great achievement of
economics if it is great so i know that
in the audience right now we have a
number of people who are uh climate
entrepreneurs uh or uh climate investors
or somehow in the private sector related
to climate energy raise your hands if
you're if you're one of those people out
here so you've got a number i think oh i
love you i know yeah um so what's your
view like you you're just talking about
sort of your your interesting structure
you have this great passage for your
first person narrative of the market
talking about like what it's done and
how it's eaten everything um what is
your view of like the role of private
enterprise private capital startups
and the market i i don't like the market
it's a it's an over simple algorithm we
give our decisions over to it and say
that they're crowdsourced but in fact
it's predatory
um the algorithm is written in with too
many externalities and it's not like two
people going down to barter i'll give
you my ox if you give me a loaf of bread
that is not what a market is anymore
it's simply a a systemic uh extraction
of value from
from working people this is classic
leftist theory and i'm totally in favor
of government over market that
essentially at this point we're like in
world war ii when governments seized the
marketplace and private industries and
said look to win this war you're doing
what we say it's a planned economy u.s
britain keynes was a big theorist to
this and we won the war in a completely
planned economy like give us all your
tin right now that kind of thing
and yet
we're in a similarly existential crisis
here where i do think governments have
to take over
but however
we're in a global capitalist system
we've only got 10 years and what i want
theoretically
um
is not going to come to pass
by a waving of the wand or by a thought
exercise we're in the world we're in and
what i'm observing is
chinese central bank has about
five trillion dollars in assets um us
for the eu about three this is what they
keep in the house in order to deal with
crises
private capital has well mark cronin
could gather um 130 trillion dollars in
assets that all promise to be green
and what i'm saying is that the central
banks have
printed tons of money in the last couple
of quantitative easings that capitalism
being what it is in this late monopoly
stage the rich have seized it all this
because it's a kind of a vacuum
suck that the more money you have the
more you can grab out of a system like
the one we're in so all the qe money has
not gone to the bottom fifty percent of
the populace but has gone to the top
there's tons of money and people are
looking at weird things like maybe i'll
buy some bitcoin and then i can sell
before it pops
that kind of excess cash lots of and
also lots of earnings of real businesses
of things that people really wanted as
well
and there's a lot of it and it's being
aggregated into asset managers so when i
wrote new york 2140 it was hedge fund
managers they were after their alpha
they were simply playing the game in
order to make lots of money for
investors that could afford to be take
risks and if they lost it it didn't
matter because it was just a pocket
change to them so you would try your
alpha was how much more percent you got
per year than the ordinary rate of
having a savings account or whatever the
average was so that was a ugly game
michael lewis exposed that game often
the big short lawyers poker but now it's
different i saw this in glasgow there
was lots of private capital coming there
going how can we green the world fast
enough to avoid catastrophe by investing
and maybe it isn't the highest rate of
return but it's the
rightest rate of return the the
they're going long on the world because
when the world crashes it's bad for
business
and so what i but there's so much
capital that and that there are asset
managers now that are dealing with
stupendous amounts i mean larry fink of
blackrock was at glasgow in fact i ate
his um excess pizza i sat down and i was
starving i said can i have this pizza
and my chinese friend head of chinese
world wildlife fund said you sure can
you're eating very things leftovers
i was starving um so but he stands for
the metaphor in that yeah there is
the science fiction writer is always
starving
um
but i saw it over and over again i i was
meeting with groups anybody who asked me
to come talk i would try to understand
what their angle was and try to
encourage them and what i saw were
groups that wanted to go green it was
more important to grow green than to max
your alpha and this i think is maybe a
sign of being scared but also of
having the right values at last
so um
you know there'll be post-capitalism one
day but right now what we need is green
capitalism and government intervention
big time and the two together are both
crucially necessary
so a couple directions go to that um
robbie nicholson is a climate
entrepreneur trying to change banking uh
asks what's the most surprising impact
that's come out of the ministry
or maybe what's the most surprising of
these invitations that you got at cop
there's a clear winner there i'm off to
do a conference with the dalai lama next
month
um so i would say that one
i thought i was beyond surprised but um
yeah that one is the clear winner
okay
i mean i'm a long now hometown guy i
mean i love long now but the dalai lama
has been a big part of my mental life
for
for um
decades and he's 87 and he's um
he's the great kyoto it's going to be
fun and it's and it's in his town you
know or dharamsala the town that the
indian government that never gave him to
be an exile in in the in the himalayan
foothills the rhododendrons will be out
and i know i shouldn't be selfish about
this but um
i never thought i'd see the himalayas
again even from the foothills or the air
and now i'm going to just to do this one
trip that's amazing and well deserved
um
one more one more finance question on
other topics uh carol block uh writes
you know we're looking at the russian
invasion of ukraine and one may be
surprising things happen as far as the
opaqueness of the financial world is is
that the swiss have dropped neutrality
and are unmasking these russian accounts
and so they will not be a clearinghouse
uh for private uh hidden uh russian
wealth yeah does that give you hope
about a future of increased transparency
that might help in this
maybe
it is a um it is the swiss dealing with
their dark past of being the bag man for
the criminals of the world and becoming
a wealthy little country that is just
entirely 65 percent a vertical mountain
range of
great beauty but low utility
and yet being extremely rich by being
the bag man the secret accounts and of
course there's the nazi gold there's the
jewish gold it is a dark past and a lot
of swiss are really
um they repress it but they're not proud
of it so at this point maybe they're
trying to make a break and and come
clean at last and now all money is
digital and it occurs to me that
although i don't believe in
cryptocurrencies whatsoever i don't see
money has
it's a medium exchange it's a storage of
value and it's a sign of social trust
and cryptocurrencies have failed all
three of these tests of money so i'm a
believer in fiat money
but and the swiss
are they've got a solid part of that and
all money is now digital i wonder if
could be trackable you don't need
blockchain blockchain is peculiar it
could be cryptography it could be a
different system it might quickly be
quantum
and then you would know where many was
you would know if it was legal or in a
tax haven i mean this gets to be
i am talking about as a statist here
like anarchists libertarians going you
got to be kidding me i mean we need to
be able to hide our money the state will
be in control
right now i want the states in control i
swear to god it's the only way we're
going to solve climate change that is
not an anarchist project that is a state
project but it needs to be member states
not sovereign states so um in that
larger picture money is important you
can't
let money slip away
into pockets where bad actors get to
continue with it at least that's my
theory you got to kill tax havens
actually taxes are a stupendously
interesting and powerful tool
for for doing good things
fantastic
um
with a relationship with state actors
and other actors as you said there's
some dark passages in ministry for the
future and one of them is climate
terrorism uh sarah schubert asks why do
you think we haven't seen climate
terrorism or violence directed at people
that are perceived as as climate
criminals and do you think there's
something that will happen in the future
that will actually change that i don't
mean left because i'm thinking of the
fermi paradox you know like why haven't
we heard from aliens and this is now
called the lanchester paradox from john
lanchester wonderful british writer good
on money good novelist
and lanchester's paradox is why aren't
we seeing this stuff same question as
sarah's i don't know
um
mckibben
has been steadfast in saying nothing
works except for non-violent resistance
that
gathers the support of the
moderates in the middle and the ordinary
citizen when they see
people
in a disciplined way staying non-violent
during civil resistance it garners their
support whereas even one bomb going off
or even extinction rebellion lying down
and blocking people on their way on
their way to work on the freeway
you gain more enemies than you gain
adherence so um this
rhetoric is the ancient greek art of
persuasion and it's worth studying a
rhetoric handbook because they had it
wired and it's a beautiful thing it's
one of the few things english majors
study that is useful and fun
um but there is no good rhetoric of
actions like and this is questions of
praxis what do you do to change power
into more healthy directions and
you have andreas malm how to blow up a
pipeline you got erica chenoweth why
civil resistance works you have mckibben
pointing to the effectiveness of a kind
of thorovian almost a christian martin
luther king
you know
lay down in front of the tanks take some
harm
and everybody's on your side because it
isn't fair
i'm not competent to discuss this
argument very well and the ministry for
the future is a mess it is not a book
you go to to sort these things out it
doesn't make a good distinction between
sabotage and murder for one thing and
badim the guy who's doing things in the
black wing of the ministry for the
future
you have to decide what badim did in the
story
by judging what you would authorize if
you were body so i cleverly snuck away
from many um statements of
responsibility on what my myself would
support stan i think something else we
saw in the book is other sorts of
unilateral actions look in the book uh
india takes it upon themselves to engage
in solar radiation management
geoengineering yeah do you think we'll
see
nations island nations anybody engaging
not only in solar radiation management
but in unilateral
pro pro-climate sorts of activities
well we certainly would have no moral
basis to object to it if they did there
isn't an international regime right now
they would not be breaking any laws
in my novel someone objects to the
indian minister on the phone i think my
mary murphy well that breaks the paris
agreement why did i write that
it's not written up in the paris
agreement that you can't do
solar radiation management
it was just an unforced error as far as
i'm concerned and i would revise it i
might even revise it going and forward
but it almost doesn't matter
maybe it implies that there was a a
treaty passed don't do this on your own
um international governance people are
working on that right now very hard
a method of deciding if whether or not
to do solar radiation management as
being global and maybe
messing with the monsoon
if india decided to do it because they
were suffering the rest of the world
would just have to say you know
okay you did it there was there would be
no sanctions and there would be no moral
right to sanction them
it is important to add to social
radiation management although we base it
on pinatubo
and sulfur dioxide which would work
sulfur dioxide uh burns up the ozone
layer and is bad in quantities so you
would need it to be limestone dust
and um limestone dust is already up
there it has similar effect it's inert
and drops back down to the ground in the
way that normal dust does
and there wouldn't be a termination
shock if you did it once it would be
like pinatubo for five years it had
lower temperatures the dust would come
to the ground you could figure out
whether you wanted to do it again as an
emergency major if people were being
cooked alive well i think this is my
role as a science fiction writer every
i'm in the man from mars everything
should be on the table
including things like this that
ordinary american liberal leftists would
say oh my god you can't do that but why
in 1990 there might have been a moral
hazard now it's all hands on deck and it
might be break glass for emergency usage
drop temperatures for five years see
what happens i mean i really think
that's a possibility
i i'm with you um on that note stuart
brandt asked what do you think of neil
stevenson's discrimination shock
oh i
i haven't read it neil and i we we are
it's this is maybe um the doppelganger
the narcissism of small differences we
don't read each other they would be a
freak out
total freak out
um i i very much like neil personally
and i've seen him
entrance a table of nasa scientists with
his um
his um
spinning table takeoff device
and he's
what pages of him i've have read from
diamond age or cryptonomic on a few
pages here there just to see what he's
like he's very funny i'm i'm envious
it's hard to write comedy and he seems
to be good at it but i don't know um
from what i've heard about termination
shock it's like come on neil we got a
serious problem here
it's it's not time to have um eagles
um
killing robots in the sky over texas or
whatever the hell um but i haven't read
it so presumably
stuart stewart does say we should box it
uh with ministry yeah box it yeah get
the yin and the yang or the kneel on the
stand i mean you have to notice this
the his baroque cycle is the same time
as my galileo's dream his seven eaves is
the same time as my aurora
and now termination shock and ministry
for the future
he has good judgment in terms of stories
all right so let's ask a couple of
questions about sci-fi itself about and
writing so kevin asks uh what would you
write differently now any of your books
you'd go back and change
oh well a couple i would i would
disappear entirely
build a zap the zap-o-matic and but
everything since
um
that that goes back into my youth i must
say and i and my youthful self would be
extremely irritated with me for being so
condescending
um
probably those are masterpieces that i
can't recognize anymore
but everything since the gold coast i
would stand i would stand by and that's
1988 so what the hell i there are
i was very intensely frustrated by
pacific edge where i didn't manage to
tell the history of how they got to
their utopia and that brought the mars
trilogy into existence i was very
frustrated with what i now call green
earth that trilogy in washington dc
science and the capital what a gnarly
beast of a place is the washington dc
bureaucracy never said a novel there um
you could see that in the novel i busted
out into rock creek park and went feral
on purpose to try to make the novel work
better but that was a frustration to me
in a couple in a couple cases
initial conditions you know fundamental
choices you make at the beginning of the
novel
you can be a really good craftsman and
technicians of novels and you're still
working on a crap idea to begin with
and so that's where i feel the stress
and strain but some people just love
pacific edge some it's corey doctorow's
favorite novel of mine um and so you
gotta
not be too ungenerous to your past self
and
i just leave it all the same
awesome last question i promise uh
what gives you the most hope for the
future
oh god well
um
well
the memory of my mom gives me the most
hope because she was a hopeful person
and she did it by
willpower it was partly biochemical but
it was partly a moral attitude you hope
first of all because you're alive and
hunger is a kind of a hope and bacteria
have hope hope is
um subtle but
omnipresence
so then political hope it's it's gramsci
pessimism of the intellect optimism of
the will
you will it as a way to go forward and
you know you do it for the future
generations you do it for the people in
the world who are immiserated right now
and like if we don't have hope how come
they have hope and so it's almost a
moral imperative so that's what gives me
hope is that hope itself is intensely
tenacious
and
it will
we're going to have to suffer some
amazing
defeats reversals confusions violences
it's going to be an unholy mess
the 2020s i guess i'll end with this
is it weird
the the are the 2020s really a critical
decade in all human history and earth on
life on earth history
that strikes me as suspicious
the the principle of mediocrity would
say we're not that special there's
something going on here we're just
worried or or we're self-important but
then when you look at everything you're
thinking well you don't want a sixth uh
sixth grade mass extinction in earth's
history
that would be big that would be hard on
us
maybe this is an important decade so you
have to be hopeful in order to squeak
through this important decade the will
to hope yeah it's a willed experience
fantastic i like that better than the
will of power so everybody stan robinson
[Music]
you